hello to you thanks for joining us um
obviously the red listing doesn't really
impact on you or or
the usa particularly but you know it's
all moving in the right direction isn't
it
yeah good morning kate it is uh we're
seeing i think uh the strongest signal
that was sent to the uk market was two
weeks ago when they finally scrapped
that useless traffic light system and
replaced it with a much simpler system
of you're vaccinated no restrictions
you're not vaccinated get it negative
pcr i think that's allowed people to
book with confidence and we're seeing
extraordinary bookings for the uh the
mid-term break
we added all of our flights to portugal
spain greece italy were filling up very
rapidly we added 300 extra flights to uh
faro to the canaries to the lyrics just
two weeks ago and most of those flights
have already uh are already sold out as
well so i think we're seeing this
pent-up demand returning very quickly um
prices are low outside of those peak
periods we're selling lots of seed sales
in late november early december but i
would urge people book early now for
christmas because it looks like
christmas is going to be a bumper time
for travel and to get the lower prices
book early
one of the problems is that people keep
getting the wrong information when it
comes to what they need and in order to
be able to fly when it comes to vaccines
and paperwork
and antigen tests and the like and
they're being given wrong information by
airlines according to which magazine how
do you try to make sure that the
information is correct
well i never believe anything comes out
of each magazine you know which is
generally all about promoting which
look the information now if you're
traveling with the eu is fundamentally
simple we've all been challenged as
airlines but constantly changing and the
biggest the guiltiest part in this was
the uk with the traffic light system
with four sets of lights instead of
three that's all now been removed it is
now fundamentally simple if you're
vaccinated certainly traveling within
the eu there is almost zero restrictions
if you're not vaccinated you will need a
negative pcr test before departure and
prior to arrival
the us would be a bit more complicated
when it starts in november because the
u.s seems to be quite nervous but again
it looks like the same simple system
you're vaccinated no restrictions you're
not vaccinated you will need negative
pcrs both
pre and after arrival but with the high
rate of vaccinations in the uk and
indeed across europe i think people are
now returning there's much more
confidence people are returning to to
officers returning to work and they're
returning to travel as well is that true
don't you need an antigen test to travel
to portugal from um
manchester or london or whatever
don't think so not if you're fully
vaccinated you do i think you do
i i defer you know
find defer to your greater knowledge job
so complicated because we
we are speaking from dublin and you've
got an eu vaccine passport we don't have
them
well uh
certainly um i i defer to your knowledge
i apologize about giving out wrong
information my understanding and it is
complicated but if you're vaccinated you
don't there's no restrictions going to
portugal it might be different from the
uk we'll check and i'm sure our website
will be updated
yeah you do you i'm sure you need an
antigen test the only reason i'm telling
you that michael is because i'm flying
in a couple of weeks i'm sure i need an
antigen test if i don't you've just
saved me 35 quid let's see um
as far as easyjet is concerned
this morning very cross with you indeed
you've been saying that easyjet and
wizard need to merge and they're saying
keep your aeroplanes off our runway
we'll do what we want
i don't mean look there's unanimity
across the industry that coming out of
code there's going to be more
consolidation in europe i didn't say
that easyjet and waze have to merge i
said it makes it's a sensible uh
development but if the easy gentleman's
don't merge it's likely that they'll
merge with other airlines in the future
i'm not sure that if windsor easyjet can
survive as independent airlines because
they're not able to compete with ryanair
on price or on cost but hey you know
it's like a family or a marriage you
know we differ from time to time we
argue from time to time the critical
thing is it doesn't matter whether the
airlines are arguing with each other or
not it's all good healthy competition
that results in more low fares for
british families traveling to the
beaches of portugal spain and italy and
particularly for the october or midterm
break and i hope again at christmas
um and and just finally we've turned a
corner now have we there's no going back
to uh the situation that we found
ourselves in with uh holidays and
flights this time last year we uh the
pandemic is in our rear-view mirror
i i think that's what we all hope and
believe i think yeah the answer to that
question is yes as long as there's no
adverse covet developments as long as we
don't see some new variant that is more
vaccine resistant you know i don't think
we can let down our guard entirely you
know you're flying with ryanair in the
next couple of weeks and months we will
still ask you to wear face masks in the
airports we'll still ask you to wear
face masks on board the aircraft unless
you're consuming
a snack or something so i think we have
to be cautious but all of the signs are
good i think the signs of economic
recovery are good jobs are being created
and certainly uh in ryanair we're seeing
very full aircraft again busy terminals
i think things are getting back to
normal that's very important for the 19
000 pilots and cabin crew the aviation
professionals we employ we want to get
everybody back to work and we enjoy
looking after our passengers and that's
what we do best
okay good to talk to you as always
thanks for joining us youtube and enjoy
the trip to portugal i hope you're fine
thank you